thank you yasser we are indeed with
pedro espinosa who scored his first
victory at the u.s junior championships
first of all pedro congratulations how
does this uh victory feels to you uh it
feels really good uh so far it's been a
rough tournament i missed a win against
bellagi i missed a draw against
christopher and then i kind of got mixed
up out of the opening against obi-wan
who's kind and got crushed in that game
so it feels good to win the game finally
today against charissa with the black
pieces a difficult opponent every
opponent is difficult in this tournament
were you surprised by her uh opening
choice definitely so i spent a while
prepping like some e4 lines i had to
actually like really good preparation
there and then she just goes like one g3
and i was like okay i mean whatever just
play chess like
and jesse you did play you actually set
up your pieces nicely let's take a look
at the game tell us the critical moments
yeah so out of the opening it was sort
of like this weird position where she
just puts her pawns on like g3 b3 a3 h3
and i wasn't really sure like what my
plan was but she doesn't have like a
clear plan either so we both just sort
of like waiting around and then
eventually she goes for like d4 and we
sort of
you know simplify a little bit
um i think at some point she missed that
i had like this queen b6 resource and
eventually went upon and then i was able
to sort of consolidate
um
how did you assess the position at this
point after d4 and all these
simplifications i wasn't really it's
probably equal i mean it's very
symmetrical um but i mean there's still
a lot of play we had of course did you
feel like uh you're on top though the
piece placement is a bit better i mean
the bishop on b2 was like a little bit
awkward i think because it's kind of
being blocked out by the d4 pawn but
it's probably still equal i can't
imagine black being like much better
here but i think she got a little bit
too ambitious
and like takes takes work f1 i think she
missed queen b6 and the points that i
can hit b flip but i also have knight
kicks g3 because there's a pin on the uh
on the king on g1 exactly and there's no
way to defend queen f3 force for knight
d2 i'm not sure if this was like a
blunder or a sacrifice or something but
i managed to win a pawn and then i won a
second pawn and you know i thought it
was going to be easy from there i was
like i'm going to win this game right
right but she had like this counter play
i mean from what i've seen chris is very
good at like creating counter play and
like being very tricky so even after i
won the second pawn it was still very
very tough and i am
and let's go all the way to the point
where you played that move queen to e8
and then she started sneaking that dark
square bishop in your position were you
a bit concerned at this point
yeah here i mean i was getting lower on
the clock and i was like am i going to
like lose this position because like i
really wasn't sure like maybe she can go
like h1 and king g3 and she can go for
some sort of like h file attack
um the bishop on d6 is very good and my
pawns aren't like that advanced so i
wasn't totally sure here but i wasn't
able to find like direct like win for
her or any way through and if you can't
get through i just go like b3b2 but you
must have been playing for a victory at
this well yeah of course of course
so let's keep going she did not find the
right moves she played this move to h1
so just uh what was your intention just
uh pedro after rook takes c8
um if she takes on c8 i'm not totally
sure what the point is like queen c8 and
like
uh like maybe like we should
oh we should be seven i missed that
which what's happening here is it's
still equal it's probably just a draw
like you have to go knight h7 and then
it's going to end up you know perpetual
yeah
take on g6
yeah bishop f6 is perpetual just
perpetual
and she did not go for this one she went
for a rook to each one because rupert
one's like very intuitive because you
don't want to create pieces like you're
attacking so i think she just like i
didn't even consider it so you actually
think that she was still playing for a
win at this point i mean i think she's
playing for counter play like she's just
trying to like like if you just like sit
around do nothing like you just like
lose so you have to go for something and
then i sound like a g5 and kind of like
trap the queen and then from there i
think it was pretty easy i just like
pushed the pawns and she can't do much
you have to be like a little bit careful
because there's something like work at
five or six ideas but
you saw those tricks and you win pretty
easily um just queen
and
nice conversion
after uh this one pedro congratulations
a big victory for you with the black
pieces just before the rest day how are
you going to spend your rest day um i'm
probably going to go hang out with some
of the friends i've made here i've been
hanging out had a lot hanging out a lot
with like brendan and andrew we're doing
some preparation together
and it's been really fun just you know
being here and just um being in st louis
and getting all these people and play
all these great players so
i'll do some preparation have some rest
and hopefully uh
keep playing well
go get uh your hangout go get your rest
and we'll see you in a couple of days
thank you
well done pedro our congratulations as
well